[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui se passe à l'odéon glisse coach
passé un peu partout en france
nous appelons et le public et les
professionnels du secteur à nous
rejoindre quotidiennement à 14h place de
l'odéon pour marquer leur soutien et de
cette façon et pour l'e mail auprès de
vouloir me manque
ça suffit maintenant nous devons ouvrir
les dîners spectacles
[Musique]
voilà
j'ai tellement
comme des lieux de consommation qui sont
ouverts au détriment des lieux de
culture et cette hypocrisie qu'il a
c'est beau c'est jamais dit clairement
etc
rageant côté
justien sentiment d'un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
peut apporter quelques duvet des
couvertures ces genres de choses pour
leur filer un coup de main pour les
soutenir
après en terme de logistique pour
l'instant on arrive à faire entrer de la
nourriture
et puis
et puis voilà on est en discussion avec
la direction du lieu
[Musique]